how is how is understanding how the
other species operates and how what they
value what they want how is
understanding them a pick me when we
always say well wait wait wait wait when
we always say that they need to
understand women they need to understand
women it's like how are you supposed to
be in a relationship with someone you
when you get in a relationship with
friends you try to understand your
friends who and you want them to
understand you so you can grow that
relationship so you could be the best
friend they have in that relationship
how are you going to be one-sided and
say oh we don't need to understand man
we don't need to know this about men
they need to understand Us and how we
operate and that's a pick me if we try
to understand how they operate to be
able to have a good relationship to not
be single at 40 with 12 kids to not die
alone with a dog how is that a pick me